Das war's für heute und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Massive Troll-Action auf YouTube am Start
Äh, kurz die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen
Pass mal auf Massive, ich muss mal kurz Discord ausmachen
Äh, Moment mal, wenn ich Discord anmache, dann gucken das nicht, dass ich im falschen Channel bin, Leute
Zack, Zack
Man weiß ja nie
Ja
Guck mal, guck mal
Der Chandler hat extra einen Troll-Account gemacht auf YouTube
Mit dem er letztens versucht hat im Stream zu trollen
Genau das gleiche
Oder, oder, es ist irgendjemand, der das nachgemacht hat
Ich mein, das ist so offensichtlich getrollt und mir fällt kein anderer ein, der das sein könnte
Schon wieder live, ja
Ah, nee, das sollte ich besser nicht ausmachen
Leider nein, ja, ja, ist klar
Chandler hat im Stream einen Screenshot gemacht von dem Kommandant, auf dem man sieht, dass er das angehört
Ich glaub keinen Screenshot, den hat er alle gefaked
Und selbst wenn nicht, der Kommentar ist, auch wenn er es nicht ist, es ist so offensichtlich getrollt, das weiß ich auch nicht
Oder es ist MrSnotty, bloß mit zweit im Account
Relaxing Mario Galaxy Musik, okay, zeig mal her
Wobei, ich finde die eigentlich äußerst people-pleased, die Musik
Die ist richtig, richtig pock, oder?
Kann man, kann man nur sagen
Der Felix ist am Start, nice
Jetzt soll ich zum Essen einladen
Einladen, also wenn du dein Abo verlängerst, ist kein Problem, dann bezahlst du dich ja quasi selbst, das ist ja, da hab ich kein Problem mit
Wusste gar nicht, dass du hier noch am Start bist, ab und zu
Ja, ich weiß aber nicht, ob ich's ihm im Stream zeigen kann
Sonst ist, ähm, Monka Tost von EA angesagt
Aber ich hab's mir angeschaut, bis jetzt gab's ja nicht all zu viel zu sehen
Ich brauch mal, ich brauch mal, ich brauch mal, ich brauch mal irgendwas entspannenderes, ich brauch irgendwas entspannenderes
Zeig mal her, was haben wir? Nintendo Summer Music
haben wir hier oh ne das ist mir zu entspannend aber nintendo summer music klingt auch gut
das ist zu viel summer ja das ist gut vorgas ja ja ich hab mir nintendo äh was war alter
ich kann nicht mehr reden ich hab mir battlefield 2042 gameplay angeschaut man muss sagen grafisch
sieht das auf youtube alles total grausam schlecht aus aber das liegt wahrscheinlich daran weil null
optimal weil weil null grafik details in dieser demo drin sind man sieht es ja auch dass die
beleuchtung gar nicht stimmt und sowas würdest du sagen es ist ok ein raspberry pi 24 7 laufen zu
lassen ohne lüfter natürlich klar also im case aber ja natürlich kannst du machen die einzige
anwendungsfall der mir einfallen würde wo das nicht der fall ist wenn du das wirklich 24 7
auslasten willst aber das hast du doch eigentlich nie kannst du machen ist gar kein problem wenn du
wenn du was richtig gutes dir holen willst dann holst du das clear case auf amazon hast du da
nicht gestern sogar schon mal danach gefragt dann kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor holt ihr dieses
case oder dieses case glaube ich das nee das ist für ein 0 holst ihr den hier und dann kannst du
jetzt happy sein was mache ich denn so dass du denkst dass ich das bin weiß nicht vielleicht
vielleicht tue ich dir auch unrecht aber ich habe irgendwie das gefühl du bist das und selbst wenn
nicht dann ja dann halt nicht das ist dass das kommt passen wir kommen rick ashley hier wenn
ich da drauf klicke junge junge ach das ist ja das kommend wo ich gedacht habe hier siehst du
nicht dass er eingeloggt ist ach so du meinst hier dass er hier eingeloggt ja klar exposed
allein schon der name und das foto dabei das kann nur fake sein oi leute ich muss noch also
wir machen es mal ich lade mir jetzt erst mal dass das aktuelle iso runter dafür wir haben uns
hier elementary us schon paar mal angeguckt die letzten zwei releases und ich muss zu sagen ich
fand das eigentlich immer ganz nice nein nein das muss man nicht kaufen eigenen betrag 0 das
ist auch eine geile taktik oder habe das gesehen das ist auch eine geile taktik das haben die das
haben die aber schon immer so runterladen wie geht das kaufen kauf kauf eigener betrag 0
download richtig richtig 5 hat time ja wir können es schon mal runterladen aber ich muss mir in der
zwischenzeit ich muss noch mal den den den einkaufen stream von gestern ein wenig extenden muss
nämlich noch zwei weitere sachen einkaufen während das iso runter lädt das iso lädt ja
offensichtlich auch nicht so schnell runter ich brauche den billigsten mikrotik poe switch den
gibt da muss ich mal kurz gucken was da was das ist der hat kein poe der hat poe das p ist
poe den brauche ich ich habe jetzt nämlich mich endlich dazu durchgerungen bei mir im keller mal
die kabel mit aj 45 stecker auszustatten und den access point in keller zu stellen der empfang bei
mir wählern technisch im keller iso dermaßen schlecht ich habe es ausprobiert durch umplatzieren
der access point im haus jetzt habe ich also durch das durch das ganze rum konfigurieren und rum
geschiebe von meinen access points im haus habe ich dafür gesorgt dass ich jetzt im haus beschissenen
empfang habe ich habe das ich mache das jetzt alles rückgängig und stellen wir noch ein
access point in keller so ich habe zwei möglichkeiten für den access point im keller entweder also ich
werde mir wahrscheinlich ein bisschen älteren unify oder unify light ap oder irgendwie sowas
sowas bestellen irgendwie ap light ein bisschen älteren weil wifi 6 im keller ist glaube ich
jetzt nicht unbedingt das was ich brauche sowas sowas hier in der richtung werde ich mir wahrscheinlich
bestellen so ich könnte natürlich auch wireless ablenken machen also sprich dass sich der access
point connectet zu dem access point über wählen also quasi zu dem im erdgeschoss aber will ich
nicht mehr ist es über kabel deutlich lieber deswegen habe ich mir jetzt überlegt wir machen
das jetzt folgendermaßen ich kaufe einen poe switch sowas da so ein hier ich kaufe einen poe
switch du musst 10g mal ich mache 10g ich mache ich mache ja schon 10g habe ja schon 10g am start
allerdings 10g in keller ist vielleicht ein wenig oversized oder du kaufst in sechser form und
montierst den alten im keller nee selbst der alte ist also ich habe ja kaum einen vorteil
von einem sechser ich habe im erdgeschoss in uap pro stehen und im ersten stock in nano hd das
sind beides access points die sind ausgelügt für ausgelegt glaube ich für 100 und 150 clients
also der unterschied zwischen denen und wifi 6 ist jetzt mal gar nicht so groß zumindest nichts
wo ich irgendwie was spüren würde von deswegen hole ich mir lieber hier einen günstigen von kann
ich eigentlich auch gleich noch hier reinlegen so und dann wird morgen kompliziert weil ich kann
euch jetzt leider das foto nicht zeigen weil ich es nicht hier habe ich habe hier im serverraum also
warte mal man sieht man sieht das glaube ich wenn ich glück habe sieht man das im ich glaube im
ersten video ja hier sieht man den kabel kanal und da ich habe schon zugemacht ich kack noob
hatte den kabel kanal schon zu warum hatte ich denn im umbau video den kabel kanal schon zu das
sagt hier auf
ne zumindest da in diesem kabel kanal dahinten da geht ein kabel von hier in den keller so und
dieses kabel ist das ist big brain handwerker time gewesen die haben das kabel genommen so
normales netzwerkabel so normales patch kabel hat ja acht acht adernpaare und davon haben die zwei
stück zweck empfremdet für analoges telefon signal das ist ziemlich dumm weil ich brauche
jetzt ein kabel mit acht adernpaaren von hier in keller so das heißt was ich morgen machen werde
ich werde morgen mal mein multimeter nehmen und mal messen welches kabel das im keller ist an
welcher stelle das rauskommt dann mache ich das den telekom anschluss ab vom kabel weil den habe
ich eh nicht mehr den benutze ich ja nicht ich habe ja komplett über über unity media und woib
jetzt brauche ich nicht so dann mache ich die kabel ab dann habe ich acht adernpaare und dann
kann ich mal das machen wo sich jeder fach informatiker natürlich darüber freut wenn er
dass man nach seiner ausbildung wieder machen kann ich kann meine eigenen stecker drauf crimpen auf
das kabel das problem ist nur jetzt kommt das sind keine litzen das sind durchgängige kabel
da drin ich weiß nicht was das für ein komisches ding ist das aber ziemlich kacke weil eigentlich
brauchst du zum stecker crimpen quasi so kleine ederchen und kein durchgängiges körperkabel nimm
doch eine dose und keinen stecker wie nimm doch eine dose und kein stecker schickt mal den link
was für eine dose ach du meinst ja aber wie soll warum soll ich dann im keller an der wand in der
luft eine dose hängen haben anstatt einen stecker dose eine kabel zu machen ist ok ok dass das der
chat chat hat ja bekanntlich bei sowas recht also nach was soll ich mal so ein netzwerk dose
oder so ein modul ihr sagt mir mal was ich suchen soll was brauche ich die stone also
die keystone ist ja eigentlich zum einsetzen dem rack in so ein klipse ding ja aber die muss
ich doch auch auflegen hinten irgendwie oder und sind die für starre kabel gedacht also aj 45
keystone ok wenn die für starke adern sind dann ist natürlich nice exzellent das muss ich jetzt
wo ist mein handy muss ich jetzt gleich vom handy aus noch bestellen das habe ich moment moment moment habe ich doch
sogar noch irgendwo moment moment ich ich habe noch welche davon
ostchamp
ja und wie soll das jetzt funktionieren das habe ich noch nie gemacht
und und wie geht das jetzt moment youtube youtube befragen
die stone ist richtig easy hier guck mal da da kriegt man da kriegt man skizzai keystone
modul ok kabel kabel ach das steckt man da einfach nur so rein das das macht das sind
einfach so so so so so eine ritze wo man das kabel rein reinschiebt oder wie das kann ich das
kein problem und dann klappt man das zu und es hält ja easy as fuck und auf der anderen
seite ist ein aj 45 stecker moment das muss schon mal kurz angucken ok da das wird jetzt da rein
gemacht alles klar das verstehe ich schraubenzieher stellts schnibbel ab rein und klappe zu ja das ist
gut das brauche ich das und auf der anderen seite sind 45 stecker sehr gut das brauche
ich amazon amazon wo bist du komm her keystone heute dienung stellts ja download läuft gerade
aus karl fensch der s-man die haben schon gute namen muss man sagen kann ich nicht
nach prime suchen oder geht das nur wenn man eingeloggt ist prime get it saturday gibt es
nicht noch was was morgen ankommt ich meine 20 uhr 16 das ist vielleicht ein bisschen knapp
moment ich muss mal kurz amazon abgucken vielleicht hat jemand big brain idee keystone 45 ich brauche
was was morgen ankommt per prime versand saturday tomorrow tomorrow beim gehen die moment gehen
die kommen morgen an das sind aber irgendwelche billigen dinger oder die sacken die will man
noch nicht oder oder taugt das moment keck wait nee die die sind um saturday tomorrow hier kw
mobile ok die die die kommen angeblich auch morgen an laut amazon ist das so was nee das
ist auch kabel samar monka es muss doch hier geben achtet mal saturday saturday saturday
ich glaube jetzt habe ich welche gefunden leute moment moment amazon für lieferbar
saturday ja das free delivery monday das ist zu das ist zu lahm ich brauche ich brauche
mir big brain time ok also was ich jetzt noch gefunden habe ist folgendes was ich jetzt
noch gefunden habe ist folgendes das habe ich noch gefunden das kommt auch bis morgen
an sicher dass da was anderes steht weiß nicht gehen die auch ja oder das sind doch
genauso welche das sind doch genauso welche die ich brauche oder ich meine da sind ein
paar dosen dabei who cares da habe ich halt paar dosen über hauptsache die sind lieferbar
bis morgen tomorrow innerhalb von drei stunden muss ich bestellen bis tomorrow ich gucke
mal kurz vielleicht finde ich noch vielleicht finde ich noch was anderes soll ich mal kurz
gucken ob die die mir eben der chat geschickt hat die der chat geschickt hat was delay
habe ich dann leg delay con negative negative latency saturday saturday saturday die gibt
es alle nicht bis morgen na super doch es gibt ein packung für 40 euro mit einem mit
einem patch panel dabei natürlich auch sinnlos bei max gibt es nur noch online ja klar warum
soll ich offline warum soll ich in den laden gehen das sehe ich überhaupt nicht ein wirklich
absolut gar nicht offline laden keck weight alter ob es geht los so bei nao ich kaufte
jetzt einfach fertig dass wir mal mit stream anfangen können sack placed order alles gut
kommt morgen mal gucken nicht dass ich jetzt falsch geordert habe delivery tomorrow jawoll
perfekt ja nice ok also exis point also da haben wir es doch hier haben wir doch für
morgen alles am start anschluss fürs kabel switch und exis point das geht nur über 24
volt power supply kann der kein 48 voll sie können ich muss die musik mal ein stückchen
leiser machen welche habe ich denn an was ist das für müll warum gibt das nur 24 kann
es 48 volt das device kommt fürs uk plug just make sure your device supports before your
power 48 volt geht auch ok dann habe ich glück weil ich ich hab noch einen also ich würde
an den router an den switch ich würde den switch halt einfach mit 48 volt so in so einem
socket für die wand power du musst ja dem switch die gleiche gleiche spannung geben
wie was du poe machen willst und ich habe glaube ich kein 24 volt power supply na gut
wenn wenn das geht dann ist in ordnung ja gut der hat mir das schon mal geklärt wichtigste
sache ist vorbei ich kann morgen mein keller upgraden ok wenn er wenn der chat sich nicht
sicher ist dann gucke ich mal nach was das alles supportet das ist ein ac light poe was
kann der alles auf dir noch die zange habe ich habe ich brauche ich alles nett ich habe
alles da ich habe alles da brauche ich net so was habe ich schon ich habe so ein komplettes
crimp setter ist sowas auch dabei
tja weiß ich nicht ich hab den ich bestell den jetzt zum ersten mal also ich habe bei
mir im ersten stock einen nano hd im erdgeschoss und uap pro und in keller will ich jetzt den
da stellen weil ich für keller jetzt nicht so viel geld ausgeben will und ja ich muss
sagen das unify zeug ist in der einrichtung nicht so easy wie es auf den ersten blick
aussieht man muss sich schon ein bisschen gedanken machen wo man die access points hinstellt
und wie man die signalstärke einstellt weil es gibt zum beispiel
probleme wenn du die access points so verteilt hast dass du im flur empfang hast von beiden
access points und beide haben ungefähr gleich starken empfang und sowas dann dann spackt
es teilweise richtig rum mega kacke das heißt meiner erfahrung nach funktioniert das am
besten wenn die access points entweder man kann die wirklich an der decke montieren zentral
im flur oder so oder man macht die wenn man sie auf die erde legen will oder vielleicht
auch an die wand man macht die übereinander falls das die die architektur her gibt weil
dann hat man den vorteil dass dort wo man auf dem stockwerk ist der access point auf
dem stockwerk auch meistens am nächsten dran ist
aber ich muss sagen dass unify zeug ist mit mehreren access points gar nicht so ich will
ich also will ich sagen nicht gut aber aber nicht so einfach wie das teilweise in youtube
videos dargestellt wird dass man sagen kann man stöpselt einfach fünf ap an und instant
ist das haus super überall toll mit wifi versorgt außerdem muss man mal sagen wenn
man ein haus hat mit halbwegs gescheiten wenden dann ist 5 5 gigahertz wlan e extremer
paint champ vor allem wenn man so komische wende hat wie jede oba gebaut hat keine ahnung
also ohne scheiß ist bei mir so ich habe im wohnzimmer habe ich das ding und wenn ich
auf dem klo sitze in der falschen ecke mag er schon nicht mehr 5 gigahertz connecten
und das sind keine ahnung sieben acht meter luftlinie dafür richtig dicke wende dazwischen
zweimal also das ist nicht ohne also wer denkt einfach
einen schönen schönen teuren nice ubiquity access point erstellt alles geht das funktioniert
vielleicht in der wohnung auf dem gleichen level aber wenn man ganzes haus versorgen
will ist das problematisch und übrigens eine einstellung müsst ihr unbedingt im unify
controller ausmachen automatic optimise hier das müsst ihr ausschalten unbedingt falls
ihr das an habt hier auch was das macht nein das nicht das meine ich nicht ihr müsst unbedingt
auto optimise network ausschalten was auto optimise network macht ist eine sache ist
ok das blockt irgendwie multicast und broadcast geschichten zwischen devices das brauchst
du in der regel im wlan eh nicht was das aber noch macht ist es forst 5 gigahertz geräte
auf 5 gigahertz das bedeutet wenn ihr in der reichweite von eurem access point seid
aber es nicht mehr für 5 gigahertz reicht dann verbindet sich euer gerät einfach nicht
auf 2,4 gigahertz und das ist mega beschissen ich habe das letzten erst ausgeschaltet also
letzten sie schon ein bisschen her ich sage jetzt einfach mal ich habe das letzten erst
ausgeschaltet seitdem habe ich im bar super empfangen halt nur 2,4 gigahertz aber ich meine
who cares das reicht ich habe ich habe wenn es hoch kommt kurz habe ich ein bisschen im
internet auf dem handy hab vielleicht youtube laufen oder ein bisschen ein bisschen musik
graben auf dem handy wenn ich schon im klo sitze da brauche ich kein 5 5 gigahertz und
150 ab daun da reicht da reichen wir 20 so lange die 5 gigahertz abdeckung folgt ja
aber ich sage immer bei mir 5 gigahertz abdeckung zu kriegen dass ich wirklich überall 5 gigahertz
hab da müsste ich vorneweg in jede etage 3 access points stellen was es mit der verkabelung
her auch wirklich gar nicht so einfach macht also ich müsste bei mir in flur wenn das ginge
ein access point hängen ich müsste bei mir auf die auf die auf die auf die straßenseite
ein access point machen und auf die auf die hofseite in access point machen wie viel bandbreite
bietet 5 gigahertz maximal das kommt vom das hängt vom netz vom vom standard ab also wenn
du i triple i 802.11 ax haben willst stimmt das was ich sage also das was allgemein in
so unter wifi 6 läuft dann kriegst du glaube ich theoretisch bis zu 1,3 gigabit oder so
was ähm aber das ist utopisch das kriegst du nicht wirklich wow ok ich hab what the
onks also jetzt mal jetzt um das ganze mal realistisch einzuordnen jetzt jetzt jetzt
mal um das ganze realistisch einzuordnen also ich hab oben bei mir eine nano hd stehen
im wohnzimmer nano hd so der kann nur wifi 5 aber das sollte das sollte eigentlich reichen
oder was kann der überhaupt für erfüllt so der hat mehrere unify seite komm mach einfach
die wollen mir werbung anzeigen und ich will nicht so also das ist ja gar nicht unify ja
also wenn man sich den anguckt den habe ich beispielsweise bei mir im ersten stoch stehen
der kann ac also das ist wifi 5 quasi noch und der ist ausgelegt jetzt nicht unbedingt
eigentlich für versorgung von irgendwelchen häusern oder so der ist eher gedacht du kannst
dein büro mit versorgen oder so wie gesagt support bis zu 200 plus usern wobei ich sagen
muss ich habe das absichtlich ein bisschen überdimensioniert weil ich habe ja ziemlich
viele iot geräte die iot geräte sind aber fast alle 2,4 gigahertz muss man sagen ja
lord jason muss ich ausprobieren ich habe keine andere möglichkeit so und so der hat
also 5 gigahertz der 4 mal 4 multi user memo das bedeutet der hat vier antennen oder kann
der kann vier gleichzeitig er kann vier endgeräte gleichzeitig bedienen oder ein endgerät was
selbst mehrere antennen hat so und wenn ich neben diesem access point stehe mit meinem
iphone 11 dann habe ich download 100 140 150 mbit also ich bin da von gigabit eine ganze
weile weg was kein was kann das iphone 11 also das kann sogar wifi 6 also das kann
auf jeden fall den alten also ich sollte theoretisch theoretisch bis zu einem gigabit bekommen
praktisch bekomme ich wenn ich mehr oder weniger neben dem access point stehe das einzige was
zwischen mir und dem access point ist ist eine dünne holzplatte ist eine dünne holzplatte
wo das ding quasi so halb dahinter hängt dass es nicht das nicht umkippt so diese wifi
bandbreite ist nicht ja ja ich weiß ich weiß das ist insgesamt das ist insgesamt bandbreite
aber es ist ja nicht so als würde neben meinem iphone jetzt noch 5 geräte 8k streams machen
oder so so und dass das funktioniert brauchst du nicht nur 5 gigahertz du brauchst auch
vor allem ein gerät mit mehreren antennen und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht wie viel
das iphone hat scheiß drauf also man sieht kabel ist immer noch beste kabel ist einfach
immer noch beste danke für den rate gestern ja nice kein ding mir ist aufgefallen ich
weiß gar nicht wie ich drauf gekommen bin ich glaube ich glaube der chain law war es
nicht irgendeiner hat es im chat gepostet da habe ich mir noch einen moment der ist
doch immer bei uns im im im chat beidstreich das kann sein ja dafür der ist doch immer
bei uns im chat da muss man eine runde hausen ja nice ich habe nur kurz reingeguckt ich
habe gesehen ihr habt wieder irgendwelche irgendwelche hacker mann geschichten gemacht
musst du unbedingt was zeigen was danach passiert ist das ist ein guter titel für den youtube
video ihr werdet nicht glauben was als nächstes geschieht so zumindest worauf ich raus will
ich bin nicht der große wifi profi ja aber ich habe damit 150 mbit direkte neben also
man kann das vergessen da irgendwie dass man jetzt einfach rumläuft und irgendwie überall
gigabit hat so und so ein ding habe ich bei mir im ersten stock und das 5 gigabit reicht
schon nicht aufs klo ich habe heute den access point anstatt ihn auch hinzulegen ich habe
den access point hochkant hingelegt dass der quasi genau in die richtung flur und klo
zeigt und jetzt kriege ich ganz am eingang also wenn ich wenn ich quasi so an der wand
bin würde ich 5 g bekommen also es ist wirklich ich sage euch ich hätte selbst nicht gedacht
aber 5 gigahertz ordentliche abdeckung das ganze haus 5 gigahertz ist schwieriger als
ich mir das vorgestellt habe zu älteren zu älteren wifi standards also was gab was gab
es denn so ihr früher noch für schöne dinger ihr g zum beispiel oder n ja zu diesen zeiten
da ging das gefühlt durch den halben garten aber ist ja auch klar erstens 2,4 gigahertz
geht einfacher durch wende durch das ist einfach so und die bandbreite ist auch geringer ich
gehe mal davon aus dass hat damit auch was zu tun und das ging easy das ging das ging
easy also ich hatte ganz am anfang hier einen access point so ganz ganz alten access point
noch so einen ganz billigen kann jemand für dummies erklären warum 2,4 gigahertz leicht
durch wende geht ja weil die wellenlänge größer ist genau kann ich dir das aber auch
nicht erklären ich kann nur sagen weil die wellenlänge größer ist also dementsprechend
die frequenz geringer aber 2,4 gigahertz geht definitiv besser durch wende haben die
leute rumgespammt bei dir im chat ja das wundert mich nicht lass mich raten der chain law war
ganz vorne mit dabei beim rumsperren könnte ich mir könnte ich mir zumindest vorstellen
schau mal wenn du magst du bist jetzt ein spam moment warte ich mach mal auf da bin
ich immer gespannt wenn man was macht wir fangen jetzt den max als pokemon habt ihr
bock drauf habt ihr da richtig habt ihr da richtig bock drauf wenn ihr das möchtet
dann müsst ihr gleich spammen und zwar ausrufezeichen catch und zwar richtig zwar richtig ihr spammt
ausrufezeichen catch wenn ihr wollt dass wir den max fangen wenn ihr das nicht wollt dann
spammt ihr ausrufezeichen escape wir starten das jetzt mal da kriegst ja brauchst die
epilepsy warnung vorher dagegen stemmen wenn ihr das nicht wollt es geht gleich los nach
diesem beat ihr macht das schon richtig ihr könnt auch danach noch irgendwelche zahlen
anhängen um mehrfach spamm zu können ihr dürft jetzt mal spam ihr dürft jetzt mal
wirklich leider kein leider kein chat mit mit dabei also ich gehe einfach mal ich gehe
einfach mal davon aus der chat hat gespammt wo ist es da ich habe gesehen guck mal der
chain war der chain war wieder voll am absperm der darf uns nicht durch die lappen gehen
macht mal kein scheiß ich sehe es genau ich sehe es genau da da ist er da war er ja ja
man wir haben max gefangen nice ja da habe ich nicht gerechnet wie ging das nice nice
nice nice nice nice leute nice die karten schauen da wurde gespammt als fuck ich sehe
schon das hier ist mobbing ich sage ich nenne doch nur tatsachen du hast gespammt offensichtlicher
geht es ja kaum und und in dem fall war es ja sogar absicht in dem fall sollte man ja
sogar spam der datenbank rebuild läuft noch ok lass uns gleich mal in die karten schauen
wo ist er wo ist er da ist er yes was für ein krasses level aber was für ein heftiges
level begegnung eins was fangquote 100 spezial attacke das ist eine coole funktion ich habe
noch nicht so ganz gecheckt aber die idee finde ich nice woher wusste ich nur dass das jetzt
kommt woher wusste ich habe es mir ich habe das nicht gesehen ohne mist ich dachte mir
nur das passt einfach gut dazu kriegt eine wunderschöne liste was ja alles möglich
ist und dann könnt ihr jetzt einfach erst mal eskalieren passiert nämlich hier immer
bin ich sehend was bin ich was bin ich sehend gerade das habe ich auch das kann ich auch
ok ok ich sehe ihr habt euch akklimatisiert natürlich was was die leute was die leute
viel mehr triggert als icq sound ist wenn man heute team sound einblendet im hintergrund
ich sehe jetzt schon die leute die jetzt nicht aufgepasst an dem skin die sachen was was
jetzt teamsnachrichten wo ist es hier was ich sehe schon hier ne leute ich muss mal kurz
licht anmachen und dass das alles home automation ist decke bamm legt es an jetzt wurde ich vom
sidetrack geside tracked ich weiß absolut nicht mehr wo ich jetzt stehen geblieben bin
leute wo bin ich stehen geblieben jetzt hat es ja drin zoom call incoming da habe ich
glück habe ich echt glück ich verwende kein zoom ich war stehen geblieben bei access points
gut hat man eigentlich alles abgehakt schon geliegtes gameplay gesehen ja habe ich man
sieht halt dass es komplett unfertiges bild ist ich habe ich habe ja selbst ein achso
du meinst dass was im chat geht
ich glaube wenn schon würde ich mal probieren wenn schon wenn schon würde ich mal probieren
sowas selbst zu programmieren aber ich muss mir mal ich muss mir mal gedanken machen ich
finde es eine echt gute idee ich melde mich noch mal ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher
so also ja mache ich mache ich so ich bin stehen geblieben bei access points so ich wollte
noch mal kurz kurz chat linux stellt ja ich wollte anfangen ich wollte ich wollte wirklich
legit wollte ich wollte anfangen ich konnte bis jetzt nicht hat man in einem eigenen haus
überhaupt großartig vorteile durch fünf gigahertz man hat auch deutlich weniger stören als in
einem mehrfamilienhaus naja man hat nachbarn und mittlerweile ist gerade 2,4 gigahertz sehr
viel los also ich finde schon dass es also ich will nicht sagen dass immer sinn macht
aber das kann sinn machen außerdem ist wobei ich bin mir gar nicht sicher wie ob das geschwindigkeitsunterschied
ist aber wahrscheinlich schon also ja also ich würde schon sagen dass man da durchaus
vorteile durch durchziehen kann zumindest und jetzt das beifall thema abzuschließen
ist viel schwerer als ich mir das gedacht habe ein haus mit 5 also 5 gigahertz empfang
abzudecken und wie gesagt diese option müsst ihr unbedingt ausschalten weil sonst sonst
forst der eure geräte auf 5 gigahertz und wenn ihr nicht in der letzten ecke 5 gigahertz
abdeckung hat verhabt funktioniert das nicht ansonsten ist das natürlich nice und noch
ein weiterer tipp für ubiquity benutzer probiert mal aus ob weniger empfang nicht mehr ist
ihr könnt bei den access points nämlich einstellen wie die wie die signalstärke ist ja tomux
genau es ist manchmal nämlich besser wenn die access points nicht überlappen oder nicht
zu sehr überlappen also sprich bei mir ist es zum beispiel so wenn ich im flur bin dann
kriege ich volle pulle von unten des ex vom unteren access point und vom oberen access
point die signale ab das geht so weit dass mein handy teilweise wenn ich in der küche
unten sitzt verwirrt ist welches access point welchen access point erst jetzt eigentlich
nehmen soll und irgendwie erst mal 20 sekunden braucht bis dann bis dann musik funktioniert
weil er zwischendrin dreimal neukonnectet ist aber auch immer dass so schlecht funktioniert
ich weiß es nicht und dann habe ich einfach mal vom vom ap pro die signalstärke auf mittel
gestellt anstatt auf auto und siehe da es gibt an viel weniger stellen problem also
auch das da kann weniger tatsächlich mehr sein also ich würde sagen das wichtigste
was man machen muss die access points sich dass sie sich möglichst wenig überlappen
und dass man die access points nur auf so viel einstellt wie wirklich sein muss also
wenn man sagt ich habe ein access point im erdgeschoss und dann geht man beispielsweise
in die eine ecke des erdgeschoss in die am weitesten entfernte ecke des erdgeschosses
und man hat noch guten empfang dann reicht die signalstärke man muss das nicht mehr
machen dann hat man auch nicht das problem dass
geräte sich dann stockwerk oben drüber mit dem unteren verbinden und das langsamer ist
also sein müsste und was auch immer ja aber da habe ich selbst gerade ein bisschen probleme
mit weil wie gesagt ich habe im keller halt mega schlechten empfang auf fette beton decke
und die ecke die unify access points die strahlen ja mehr mehr nach vorne ab und ich habe die
halt nicht an der decke montiert das heißt ich müsste die quasi auf den kopf stellen
dass er schön in keller dingst aber dann kriegen die anderen im erdgeschoss nicht mehr genug
also ich werde ich bin da morgen mal gespannt also dafür muss ich mir nämlich den ganzen
kram bestellen hier access point access point für den keller poe switch für den keller
weil wenn schon mache ich es richtig keystone module für das kabel und da muss ich morgen
mal suchen und kabels auflegen dann kriege ich nämlich gigabit runter in keller hier
durch durch den kabel kanal kabel liegen ja gigabit in keller switch dran router access
point dran und dann mal gucken ach ja ich wollte ja noch schnell gucken was das ding
für nen poe hier der kann nur 24 volt da muss ich meinen router mit 24 volt betreiben
das ist ja auch müll ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob ich den 24 volt 802 was kann der
denn was kann der denn für poe standards ok da kann 802.3 af ist das ist das 48 ist gigabit
aber wo davon zu vielleicht keine ahnung das 48 volt weiß man nicht was 44 die bei den
ganzen netzwerkstandards blicken immer da durch das 48 volt ok das ist 48 gut da kann ich
also doch mit einem 48 volt betreiben netzteil alles klar gut nice gut jetzt machen wir die
nukstells jetzt können wir endlich anfangen wir haben noch eineinhalb stunden zeit poggers
also install neu vm oder kann ich irgendeine out leute chat chat darf ich darf ich die
cute vm recycle nicht die cute vm ok neue vm ich sehe es schon alles klar ist gut ist
neu fahren weeps out cute vm überschrieben ne ne machen wir nicht machen wir nicht next
linux jubantu gucken da ist elementary doch bestimmt nicht drinne juba weil elementary
nicht in den ubuntu remix müssen wir mal nachgucken gleich wir schauen gleich mal nach
elementary location ist ja komplett verkehrt die location muss e vms make elementary ist
falsch geschrieben aber wen juckts 4 cpu kerne ne 1 cpu 4 kerne 8g ram sollte mal reichen
nutt ist auch in ordnung jawoll jawoll new disk single file akon 40g elementary vmdk customise
hardware drucker muss raus soundcard ja kommen wir mal drinnen lassen alles klar zack finish
was hast denn jetzt wieder für emotes ausgebuddelt wo ist der sinn davon vor allem in kleiner
variante erkennt man ne das emote finde ich doof aber dann erkennt man guck mal leute
guck mal guck mal man erkennt das man erkennt das doch überhaupt nicht also guck mal hier
die normalen leute im chat erkennt man doch gar nichts ja wenn sd wenn sd mal ausreicht
sd ist ja bei uns quasi sowas wie paal und paal ist ja was 720 x 586 oder sowas da sieht
ja da ist ja snes grafik noch hi rest dagegen ich habe schon viele emotes geerdet die du
vorgeschlagen hast aber das gefällt mir nicht er hat ja muss man ja mal lassen er hat ja
schon er hat ja schon ein gutes gespür für emotes ok jetzt sehen wir mal hier die cd
dran weil die cd dran hängen ist glaube ich im jahr 2021 beinahe vm oder iso nicht mehr
wirklich zeitgemäß der ausdruck oder die cd dran hängen ist schon ziemlich boomer talk
ich glaube die leute die heutzutage so vom rechner sitzen die wissen gar nicht mal wie
ein cd laufwerk überhaupt aussieht dvd auch nicht blu ray auch ne doch von der playstation
mit blu ray das wissen sie hat die neue playstation auch noch blu ray laufwerk ja bestimmt oder
i finished install try jawoll es gibt eine ach so bei playstation ich dachte es ist nur
bei der xbox so dass es irgendwie xbox mit und ohne laufwerk gibt ja wenn man sich überlegt
mit micro sd karten haben mehr speicherplatz als blu ray also etwas teurere micro sd karten
geschwindigkeitsmäßig keine ahnung da ist wahrscheinlich zumindest sequenziell blu
ray schneller so jetzt können wir uns den huge linux mac os fake angucken asa bei jan
sehr gut brava seleccione ach ne das ist jetzt gar nicht asa bei janisch englisch chinese
ich habs kaputt gemacht leute ich hab den insta ich ah jetzt gehts wieder ich hab ich
hab hallo ich hab ich hab was ist das please fängt schon gut an ich glaube der macht
irgendwo nen fenster auf was er nicht machen sollte ok united states perfekt sag mal ist
unsere auflösung zu klein um es überhaupt zu installieren sehe ich das richtig ist unser
installer zu klein zum installieren ok das geht gut los ok plin flug enter drücken geht
nicht fuck verschieben geht auch nicht ok dann braucht man irgendwelche kornelparameter
dann braucht man bestimmt irgendwelche kornelparameter damit ich den kram umstellen kann ok ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass es so kompliziert schon anfängt ich hätte ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass es so kompliziert anfängt ok neustart über control an ein fern geht auch nicht
das ging das letzte mal elementary os technisch aber noch so booting keine escape drücken
aber können wir irgendwie edit options ähm wie geht man jetzt die auflösung ein wir
fragen mal wir fragen mal google elementary os install vmw äh resolution ok wir müssen
irgendwas neuere suchen letztes jahr über vielleicht mag er das stretchen ich hab das
stretchen ausgeschaltet install resolution minimum display resolution gut das kann mein
display aber wahrscheinlich nur mit vmw tools grafiktreiber specify ja das ist egal
x render können wir machen aber man kann krab auch krab auch sagen welche auflösung
man haben will krab change resolution ja warte mal rub gfx mode mach vga gleich ask dahinter
ok big brain time gucken ob das funktioniert press massive brain chat press enter to set
video modes available ah ja ok alles klar 364 brauche ich 364 klingt doch gut 1000
hurdachs mal 720 230 bit farbtiefe so jetzt jetzt die frage geht das jetzt oder nicht
es sieht immer noch ziemlich klein aus warum ist bei strikes noch kein whip das ist eine
gute idee das konnten wir echt machen ich frag mal die mods was die mods dazu sagen
guck mal leute bäm richtig 5 hat time ok englisch united states select ja
ist der installer broken ach hier muss ich jetzt select machen ich dachte man macht
das im main menu keyboard layout german ah ne oh diese menus ich krieg anfälle wo ist
er hier german no dead keys ok weiter demo mode erase disk and install bäm jawoll don't
encrypt brauchen wir jetzt nicht was bedeutet no dead keys das ist dieser das ist diese
genau das auf tastatur das ist das sogenannte es ist nicht das circom flex circom flex ist
das da das ist name of symbol das ist ein ich sag immer hütchen aber das stimmt auch
nicht moment ist doch das circom flex moment was ist dann das ach das ist decree oder
habe ich vertan ich habe euch miss erzählt monach esstheim das ist das natürlich dass
das teils begraben das war doch circom flex also es ist ja ich habe das richtige wort
aber falsch verwendet dass das circom flex und normalerweise muss man auch unter windows
das circom flex doppelt drücken dass es überhaupt auftaucht und no dead keys bedeutet ich muss
es nur einmal drücken dass es auftaucht no dead keys ich habe ansonsten aber keine ahnung
was es noch macht was sind no dead keys ok das kriegen wir schon erklärt akzent wie
macht man dann so sachen wie er gar nicht die kopiert man sich einfach copy paste copy
paste aus google oder an irgendeiner symbol table das lässt man einfach das macht man
einfach gar nicht vor der weeps was was haben wir sonst noch vorgeschlagen was das wir haben
schon genug wie im aus guck mal die hälfte unserer emotes sind noch aus der zeit oder
sie baro regelmäßig da war die bestehen zur hälfte aus irgendwelchen anime dingern
so select was ist das jetzt moment hat er fertig installiert neu gestartet und ich
er hat einfach von cd gebootet und soll er nicht okay ich mache die cd nochmal weg und
reboot neu geht nicht power reset ja das ist genau das was ich gesagt habe er hat eigentlich
schon installiert aber hat es noch mal von cd wie warum nochmal select language der button
da unten das macht das macht mich fertig ok united states select wir treffen hier keyboard
layout nein nicht dutch german sind es ja fast so schlimm wie unter windows den kram auszuwählen
german no that key ich hoffe mal der ist der richtige ja ok name komm der bald strike
war big brain der kriegt heute username choose password 123456 best practice password enter
da sind wir 123456 zack wie kommt man eigentlich wie bekommt man eigentlich die cute vm du
installierst nur buntu dann installierst du mo buntu als skin zeige ich dir gleich jetzt
erstmal forever tools kurz draufhauen terminal ich sehe schon wir haben keine 3d beschleunigung
aktiviert glaube das müssen wir gleich mal nachholen ich vergesse immer wo das ist da
nie ist ist ok sudo minus ich glaube es ist ubuntu basiert ab install open erst mal update
machen eisflug dankeschön 20 monat hier hyper subscription richtig nice kurz nachgucken
was über nordic habe ich auch übersehen dankeschön zwei monate maxres sechs monate am start
2 monate ab install was wie hieß der kram jetzt open vm tools desktop wieso ich lese
doch viel chat halt nicht permanent ich muss ja auch was machen guck mal da bärm vollbild
jawoll so muss das sein so mag ich das also ich zeige das mal wie du mo buntu bekommst
du installierst ubuntu und dann installierst du diesen komischen skin aus dubioser quelle
und dann hast du mo buntu ich sag nicht umsonst aus dubioser quelle weil naja naja halt ne
also wenn du dir das installieren willst dann kannst du das machen ich habs eigentlich
aber just for fun gemacht es ist halt äußerst vertrauenswürdig von da zu installieren das
ist mac os clone ja wie verschiebt man überhaupt fenster a windows tastige drücktheiten dann
vergeb mal rechte whip zu machen ähm ich weiß gar nicht wie das geht ne keine ahnung
wie das geht weiß nicht wie man rechte vergibt um slash whip username ja das weiß ich aber
wie ich rechte vergebe um whip zu machen das weiß ich nicht da bin ich überfragt
gar nicht glaube ich kann auch sein abgegoogelt geht nicht pack weight so also welcome oh guck
mal man kann man kann gesten gesten per gesten scrollen da muss ich selber machen ja wir
bleiben jetzt erstmal beim usernamen vor der distribution für big brain install so basic
guide genau das richtige für mich ich lese nie guides was ist denn das für nen browser
standardmäßig preferences das ist ist das der ist das der gro der der gnome standard
browser oder was ist denn das was ist das für nen browser irgendwas was man nicht verwenden
will glaube was ist denn das ich hab nen plan wie man das überhaupt rausbekommt ok vielleicht
hier internet web das ist so ein shit ding das nur elementary verwendet die haben ihr
eigenes warum haben die nen eigenen browser das letzte wo ich selbst selbst was drehen
würde ist doch nen browser epiphan das ist der standard gnome browser das ist kein elementary
ding wenns epiphani oder wie man das ausspricht ist aber wo bekomme ich denn raus was es ist
das muss doch hier irgendwo irgendwo steht so about oder sowas about gibts net der verwendet
auch webkit das ist quasi der safari der linux browser about about das ne gute idee
about about die haben schließen auf der linken seite das macht das triggert triggert triggert
whats my user agent ja das zeigen doch aktuelle browser nicht mehr so wirklich an ohne ip
leak ok glaubt ihr das jetzt mal ohne ip leak hallo ich kann nicht reinkopieren was war
das whats oh das muss ich ausschalten das nervt mich jetzt schon whatsmyua.info hier
wir haben mozilla apple webkit safari weils ein webkit ist nein es ist kein safari ich
sag ja noch eben aus spaß der safari für linux oh nee please gehst du mal weg warum
haben die da was warum haben die ausgerechnet für browser was eigenes das verstehe ich
nicht geht da so sachen wie youtube gescheit abspielen mal gucken mal gucken was unter
dem aktuellen video geht was geht denn so in dem aktuellen video ja hier ist der max
der ist auch hier ist er auch steht und fällt mit mapflow genauso siehts aus ok aber video
scheint zu funktionieren erstmal 1044p bam und auslastung auslastung 1440p 100% cpu jawoll
so muss es sein und fullscreen ich mein es läuft immerhin zwar flüssig ist was anderes
aber wenn es erstmal abspielt dann scheint es halbwegs zu laufen das ist hardtop gut
warum die so einen komischen browser dabei haben weiß ich nicht oh was hab ich jetzt
gemacht was zum was das ist das ist maximieren das ist fulls nee moment was ist f11 f11 ist
fullscreen auf dem zweiten desktop oder sowas ok kann das alles f11 nee das kann man f11
aber sagen wir mal den kalender den kann man bestimmt nicht f11 nee ok ich mags jetzt
ich muss ehrlich sagen ich mags auch schon nicht es ist nicht ich will jetzt nicht sagen
dass sie sich nicht mühe gegeben haben die haben sich offensichtlich viel mühe gegeben
aber es ist nicht mein wie soll ich sagen workflow bis jetzt so als erstes muss ich
hier auch nochmal die background transparency ausschalten wie schalte ich background transparency
aus das muss weg das das nervt mich immer richtig bei einem terminal wenn die background
wenn wir ganz prärent den background haben das geht mir voll auf den kick ok das das
geht hier an der stelle anscheinend nicht was ist das multitasking ok wie komme ich
in die settings appcenter ok das ist der standard gnome appcenter glaube interessiert uns jetzt
nicht so wie komme ich in die settings da oben user account settings ich will keine
user account settings ich will user account settings all settings ja wie komme ich dahin
wie ist er wie ist er ah das hier sind settings system settings da unten so und hier kann
man hier terminal einstellen nee man muss doch einstellen können dass der kein transparenten
hintergrund hat für das terminal
so das muss doch das muss doch settings ok das ist zu advanced wisst ihr was auch sein
kann dass das einfach so so diese mac os design mentalität ist wenn es dir nicht gefällt
dann hast du pech gehabt max bist du albaner nee ich bin nicht albaner ich bin offenbacher
um es genau zu sagen bin in offenbach geboren ich wohne in hanau und ich arbeite in frankfurt
wenn du so willst bin ich nicht weit bin ich nicht weit gekommen offenbacher wobei offenbach
muss man sagen offenbacher dass man da albaner wäre kann durchaus sein ist offenbach nicht
die stadt gerade also in in in auf jeden fall im rhein-mein-gebiet mit dem höchsten ausländer
anteil besser stelle ich hier rein also ich glaube offenbach hat da in der vergangenheit
auch schon die ein oder andere mittlere maustaste geht nicht copy paste es gibt ernsthaft den
linux terminal was nicht mittlere maustaste copy paste macht wirklich hier shortcuts don't
require shift oh nee das gefällt mir gar nicht das gefällt
mir gar nicht ich will mittlere maustaste haben für copy paste max macht feature mit
haftbefehl ja ich weiß weil ich offenbacher bin das das wäre es doch oder haftbefehl
features informatikorr goethe straße louis vitor store zahlt die kollektion barf pick
auf sponsor einzige was ich kenne von haftbefehl aber immerhin kenne ich was hat er ja recht
hat er ja recht ja fick auf sponsor wobei ich sagen muss ich finde sponsor eigentlich
ganz nice wo wir bei der gelegenheit vielleicht mal meinen sponsor erwähnen können ausrufezeichen
hetzner im chat wenn ihr auf der suche nach einem holster seid für eure linux vm dann
ist hetzner der holster meiner wahl benutze ich selbst schon die letzten paar jahre über
bin eigentlich bis jetzt immer damit zufrieden gewesen könnt ihr innerhalb von ein paar minuten
neue linux vms erzeugen und werdet stündlich abgerechnet das heißt wenn ihr mal was fettes
braucht was 350 euro im monat kostet kauft ihr euch das löscht nach fünf stunden wieder
und bezahlt nur den euro geht doch bot nicht ah doch genau könnt ihr euch anmelden könnt
ihr euch anmelden mit meinem code bekommt ihr 20 euro startguthaben einlösbar bis
ende des jahres und mit 20 euro startguthaben könnt ihr schon von den kleineren surfern
ein paar einige monate betreiben etzner vor 20 jahren schon gehabt sehr gut ja beste würde
zu etzner wechseln wenn haftbefehl ist empfiehlt könnt ihr meine offizielle anfrage stellen
kannst die windows ja in der linux virtualisieren was ne das sagt wenn aus unter linux virtualisieren
das ist mist das ist mist das geht aber das ist mist so also wo sind wir stehen wir haben
schon mal kein copy paste im terminal das ist das ist doof das ist doof das gibt das
gefällt mir schon mal überhaupt gar nicht was will was will der hier eigentlich dark
7 wollen wir haben jawoll finde ich schon mal gut so blau was ist das eigentlich turkis
kappa bright ne das ist das ist zufallsfarbe glaube bleib mal hierbei next nightlight ja
housekeeping trashed files online accounts connecten wir nicht apps immer muss sagen
die haben sich schon mühe gegeben da kann es nix sagen ändert sich das jetzt ich sehe
hier kein unterschied es könnte aber einer vm liegen dass das nicht geht terminator
mag ich nicht genau im terminal beste genau im terminal tmax und und haste und gib ihm
aber ich will dir die voll sachen mir ein bisschen angucken weil das ist ja das was
so die die die aushängeschilder da letztendlich sind also das terminal gefällt mir nicht nicht
gut muss ich sagen so wobei ich sagen muss das standard mac os terminal also ich benutze
kein mac os selbst scheint auch nicht so geil zu sein es installiert aber unter mac os jeder
so nen so nen frag ich war wie heißt denn das so nen so nen zweites terminal was wohl
richtig geil ist was so wohl alles hat was man irgendwie haben will i term 2 genau genau
genau das meine ich das hat sogar wohl tmax unterstützung dass du tabs sünden kannst
mit tmax tabs und sowas eigentlich richtig nice habe ich so unter linux noch nicht gesehen
so also was man hier einstellen kann ist für uns ziemlich uninteressant so also das terminal
gefällt mir schon mal nicht der standard browser gefällt mir auch nicht jetzt gucken wir mal
was man so nach installieren können kriegen wir kriegen wir den aktuellen kronen wir kriegen
den aktuellen chrome firefox vielleicht was jetzt ernsthaft muss das erst mal muss ich
das erst einmal zünden oder wie ok update edge bestimmt edge läuft darauf windows advanced
threat protect was zum teufel habe ich jetzt gemacht advanced threat protection ja wahrscheinlich
schon die läuft ja unter linux ich sehe das auf der arbeit jeden tag ok internet was kann
man da so das ist alles es gibt vier programme für internet und eins davon kostet 3 euro
was so was ernsthaft hallo ich möchte ok windows taster macht die hilfe auf anstatt
die anstatt des application menü application menü ist space ok was du kannst den preis
wählen wirklich null ist wieder das gleiche warum nicht einfach warum warum warum windows
taster lehrtaste software kann man vielleicht noch irgendwie mehr installieren ist das ding
von apple die wollen die wollen krass apple style machen habe ich den eindruck hier ok
office ok ich muss mir jetzt mal den heiße artikel durchlesen was da dran so was da dran
so geil ist ich weiß noch mir hat es das letzte mal auch glaubt letzte mal hat mir das eigentlich
ganz gut gefallen aber ich hatte damals auch schon so meine probleme dass das so so mecki
ist so so elementarie was ist das ja um update center available haben wir doch grad schon
gemacht also die liegungsdistribution bla bla bla das modernisierte app center ok das
app center ist so krass modernisiert guck mal ich kann doch mal die werbung zumachen
in diesem browser oder ich glaube das ist absicht kann man für den browser kann man
nicht mal werbeblocker und so installieren gut das flickern beim resize das liegt definitiv
an der vm da würde ich mir keine gedanken machen dass es normalerweise so ist das app
center wurde so modernisiert dass nur noch fünf apps pro kategorie da sind zwei jahre
entwicklungszeit aber guck mal die notifications haben nicht erkannt eben dass sie schon updates
gemacht haben das ist weiterhin drin geblieben die erste auffällige änderung ist das neue
installationsprogramm ja die habe ich auch gemerkt die hat dazu geführt dass ich nicht
installieren konnte gut das hat man hat man schon wandelbarer look leicht zu bedienen
der einheitliche oberfläche ich kann auch nicht mal mit control windows taste zoomen
das ist was ist das für ein ding what the fuck das muss suma betriebssystem sein ja
zu viele funktionen auf einmal überfordert die leute der scheint die pakete nicht zu
finden sehr gut ich überleg grad was soll ich was soll ich mal soll ich mal rebooten
da ist überhaupt nichts drin muss ich das irgendwie refreshen oder so ich meine ich
mache einfach noch mal update update ansonsten hast du hier keine option du kannst da nichts
machen internet ne da sind nur vier programme drin ach das sind nur programme die explizit
für elementary 6 freigegeben wurden ja gut das ist ja echt naja also nix aktuell zumindest
der installer ist kostenlos war da habe ich aber glück gehabt da habe ich aber glück
gehabt dass das das ist die wollen dass du flat pack verwendest ja aber die wollen doch
nicht ernsthaft bei so einem bling bling gui ding dass ich flat pack update mache oder
sowas ne erstmal ist ok da bin ich jetzt bissl enttäuscht haben wir hier das ist nautilus
oder das ist nautilus oder ist das was eigenes ich würde sagen das ist was eigenes das ist
irgendwas eigenes was sie gestrickt haben als file manager sobald du ein flat pack installiert
hast ist die quelle auch im store registriert ok das ist schon ein bisschen fail also das
heißt ich muss da jetzt ins terminal und muss sagen zum beispiel keine ahnung was gibt
es denn da schönes flat pack install sagt mir mal was vlc ne ach wie geht denn das jetzt
flat pack vlc firefox warum ist die quelle nicht direkt registriert ja flat hub ok das
finde ich jetzt nicht so nicht so angenehm flat pack install flat hub org flat hub org
video vlc das ich weiß nicht kann ich das installieren ohne rootrechte gut also ich
bin nicht in der lage sachen zu installieren das finde ich schon mal nicht gut ich muss
den kram wahrscheinlich vorher enden oder so aber warum ich meine die machen das doch
explizit für easy bedienung können wir nicht erzählen dass das easy bedienung ist da komme
ich mir fast wie ohne windows 11 vor es fehlt bloß noch das heißt hi im cortana starte
mal neu das ist eine gute idee reboot für flimmer
leute wisst ihr was das beste ist morgen schon wieder freitag
auch mal gucken ob es jetzt geht muss bei flat pack glaube ich flat hub atten das sehe
ich überhaupt nicht ein aber ja ist sehr dumm gemacht ja ja das ist wirklich wirklich
blöd stream streak habt ihr da mehr informationen wie viele wie viele tage am tag habe ich habe
ich gestrickt schon mehr gibt es nicht ok das ist wirklich massif blöd gemacht so was
gibt es dann überhaupt etwas was ich damit machen kann ich wollte jetzt gerade wishell
studio code nach inszenieren aber das geht ja auch nicht code ich es gibt ja ein moment
hier doch das da oder nee das ist denen ihren was soll ich denn damit überhaupt machen
jetzt immer ernsthaft was soll ich damit machen es gibt ja nix
flat pack remote at flat hub ja ja ok moment das muss das muss wir gucken uns jetzt mal
den user guide an moment das muss ich mir jetzt angucken was was schreiben die denn jetzt
offiziell user guide elementary os user guide elementary os user guide learning the basics
er das krieg ich hin flat er fällt mir nix zu flat some third parties of may not be available
especially if it's cross platform you can sign on flat pack app from third party flat
hub download and open a flat pack ref or flat pack file and then sideload utility das ist
ja das ist ja schlimmer als unter android ok ich will in firefox sideload good good
install flat pack ref ok öffnen ok das ist wirklich ein bisschen wie früher unter mac
kennt das noch jemand wo man früher unter mac den installer track und dropen musste
wo so ein installer aufging und man das dann in diesen ordner ziehen musste so ein bisschen
ist das hier hier install untrusted das erschaffte also das ich weiß nicht warum genau bitte
schön nicht firefox über die ubuntu quellen benutzen ab search firefox
ja das könnte ich mal machen aber aber warum warum jetzt mal ich verstehe es nicht warum
warum ziehen die das hier vor versus über einen meinetwegen über ein gui oder halt
zu sagen nimmt den package manager wo ist denn davon jetzt der sinn das verstehe ich
nicht das leuchtet mir wirklich absolut jetzt grad gar nicht ein ok was gibt es denn da
alles zu installieren so also mozilla firefox hatten wir jetzt visual studio gibt es das
da auch noch ok die os variante leider kann ich die os variante nicht verwenden weil ich
für Arduino und esp 32 microcontroller plattformen auch brauche die verwenden eine proprietäre
c++ komponente die nur im original visual studio geht die legs critical information
ja offensichtlich die entwickler auch ich meine das ist ja fast so schlimm wie unter
windows ja ok ich install die untrusted app alles klar 1,1 g also entweder bin ich zu
dumm die genialität zu verstehen oder es ist einfach wirklich blödsinnig wozu was will
man damit ok mal heiße kommentare gucken was da geflamed geflamed wird vielleicht bessere
touch support juckt mich jetzt überhaupt nicht flat pack für die softwareversorgung
wichtiger bestandteil ist das app center gut im app center ist ja nichts drille ich finde
es an sich nicht schlecht wenn dort kuratierte anwendung auftauchen da weiß man wenigstens
die fügen sich gut ein aber es gibt ja aktuell nix also installierst du kannst damit nix
machen an sich finde ich die ideen ja nicht schlecht wie das ist wie leer gefegt ja genau
package format unbetreute anwendung ok naja tasks app haben wir jetzt ui massive an to
do tool kann es kann es markt dauernd und das ja ich mein immer noch besser als das
nex cloud to do tool das nex cloud to do tool ist nämlich müll aber das ist halt eine
to do app es ist halt es ist halt eine einfache to do app sowas sowas ich will ich will ihn
jetzt nicht wirklich nicht unrecht tun aber sowas hast du doch in drei tagen programmiert
und es ist wahrscheinlich noch großzügig ok online zink definitiv nicht in drei tagen
aber wie gesagt ich will den echt nicht unrecht tun jetzt ich finde es geil wenn leute sich
die arbeit machen für andere sowas zu bauen aber ich sehe den sinn kann echt nicht
im editor code hat das team die integration weiter ausgebaut jetzt mal ernsthaft gibt
es wirklich jemand der den eingebauten code editor verwendet ich mein jeder der das ernsthaft
machen will installiert sich seine passende idee und und visual studio code für frontend zeug
ok warum warum dass der weitere code editor hat doch eigentlich überhaupt keine da seins
berechtigung das einzige was was der für die da seins berechtigung hat ist dass der hintergrund
zum jeweiligen betriebssystem theme passt aber selbst das hätte man meinetwegen mit
den original studio code extension oder was auch immer lösen können bei erreichen arbeitest
du drei tage exklusiv mit elementen das das erreiche ich dann auch noch und da muss ich
mich dann ich will mich ja nicht selber geißeln hier wobei donation gold würde ich zumindest
geld dafür kriegen dass ich den kram verwende eigentlich ist es eine gute idee eigentlich
ist es eine gute idee ich finde die idee gar nicht so gar nicht so schlecht wie soll ich
das machen drei tage nur elementary ich meine da gibt es ja nichts drauf was ich brauche
ich kann davon auch nicht mal gescheit homo na doch ich sag mal so ich würde dann einfach
alles über ubuntu nachinstallieren über die ubuntu repos dann habe ich mehr oder weniger
ubuntu aber es ist halt es steht halt dann elementary drauf ok hat jetzt hat jetzt flat
pack nachinstalliert hier will er noch was von mir visual studio code has been installed
alles klar vergesst nicht twitch prime die kostenlose möglichkeit einen streamer streamerin
deiner wahl zu unterstützen das ist richtig aber twitch hat gesagt bzw jeff möchte mehr
geld von prime subs deswegen kriegen wir jetzt weniger von prime subs ab warning you are
running an unofficial flat pack version of visual studio code das wirkt alles nicht vertrauenswürdig
was ich hier sehe findet ihr das irgendwie warum was spricht denn gegen ein offizielles
repo zum installieren ich verstehe das nicht ich meine der vorteil von einem package manager
unter linux versus windows ich bin unter windows immer am flamen dass es keinen gescheiten
package manager hat und jetzt mit win jetzt so was halbherziges kommt was leider nicht
besser geht weil das da so ein wildwuchs entstanden ist die letzten die letzten 20 30 jahre ich
verstehe es nicht ich ich check es nicht es ist echt sus genau richtig sus ist das schlechter
als win also das hier ist auf jeden fall schlechter als win get das heißt schon was
eventuell die kosten für die unterhaltung der repositories naja wenn die zu also wenn
die zu wenig user haben dann tut sie auch ein einfacher server der nicht viel kostet
zum beispiel bei meinem partner hetsner ich habe versucht wirklich seriös den zellot
ein zu machen habe es aber nicht geschafft ok zum beispiel meinem partner könnte ihr
euch für 2 euro 90 im monat schon in linux cloudserver buchen der für einfache sachen
wie beispielsweise ein reposerver voll und ganz ausreicht zumal zumal er auch noch inklusive
traffic bekommt der eigentlich für alles reicht gut wenn man jetzt den repo betreiben
will dann würde ich wegen dem traffic vielleicht mal gucken weil man hat bloß 20 terabyte
aber die 20 terabyte beziehen sich auch nur auf ich glaube ausgehenden traffic und nicht
eingehenden traffic die haben alles was unter linux geiles rausgemessen den eindruck habe
ich auch also ich finde das sehr sus dieses ganze zeug hier mit flatpak zumal an sich
an sich habe ich ja da gar nichts gegen aber dieses nachinstallieren über über den browser
und dann das erinnert mich schon an wenn was kommt als nächstes registry oder was ok
wo wir gerade beim thema registry sehen ich fürchte das bleibt uns doch nicht erspart
ich meine terminal elementary os transparent background disable ich glaube wir müssen
jetzt quasi in so eine elementary ja ich glaube die haben nämlich ne settings geconf oder
sowas g settings ich weiß ja nicht mal was ich suchen muss hier g settings ich muss das
wirklich ich muss das wirklich über registry geschichten machen
ne ne ne leute ne wirklich net also optisch haben sie sich mühe gegeben keine frage ich
will jetzt auch nicht schlechter machen als sie es verdient haben aber ich sehe da kein
betriebssystem für mich dass ich es aber so dass ich nicht täglich benutzen werde weil
ich mit meinem aktuellen manjaro mit e3 voll und ganz zufrieden bin war eh klar aber ich
würde es auch so nicht verwenden hätte ich das nicht also das ist das ist wirklich kein
os für mich wie gesagt ohne die jetzt schlechter machen zu wollen als es verdient haben aber
ne ne ich will auch gar nicht weiter gucken wenn ich ehrlich bin schock mich net schock
mich echt net das letzte fand ich glaube ich noch ganz brauchbar installier mal e3
drauf ok das kann das können wir noch machen was ist deren zielgruppe das verstehe ich
auch nicht ich wahrscheinlich sie selber wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich sie selber so was sie selber
gerne hätten anders kann ich mir das net vorstellen weiß ich was die zielgruppe ist
mac user können es ja nicht sein windows user offensichtlich auch net linux user ich kann
es mir nicht vorstellen ich meine ich kann e3 darauf installieren das wird aber nix bringen
weil das halt über die ubuntu repos kommt das ist das standard das standard mäßige
e3 was halt bei ubuntu dabei ist mal gucken ob man das im login manager überhaupt auswählen
kann leute die mit hübschen desktop im starbucks sitzen wollen dann würde ich mir fast schon
eher chrome os installieren gibt es ja mittlerweile auch zum selbst installieren und wenn es danach
geht da kannst du noch mehr mit machen ja gab's ist standardmäßig nicht dabei sonst hätte
ich auch gab's installiert es gibt echt leute im chat die das verwenden wirklich ja dann
wird mich interessieren was was euer was für ein anreiz für euch da ist also warum warum
verwendet ihr das was was gibt euch das was sonst nicht gibt achso moment
die drei bärm zack
das ja zum heulen das sieht ja mega kacke aus
nicht wirklich aber es läuft viel es läuft mega schnell gleich aber gut es ist halt auch
es zahlt es zahlt die drei so dem menü dass überhaupt noch was was was starten kann dem
menü wie heißt dieser browser sensible browser er kennt den auch nicht mal den browser weiß
gar nicht wie ich ein browser starten würde web get web browser browse braucht diese raspbar
ne brauch ich nicht ich will jetzt nicht e3 hier drauf auch einrichten weil es hat überhaupt
keinen sinn e3 status kann ich machen ja so mein schön ist es also das andere ist definitiv
hübscher das ist aber auch nicht die distro wo ich hier mit mir drei anfangen würde der
eiswiesel der ist bestimmt noch da ich überlege ganz ernsthaft was wie bekomme ich wie bekomme
ich jetzt hier den browser auf ich meine klar was ich kann immer noch sagen ab install firefox
browser und das kommt dann über die ubuntu repos aber das ist unsinnig das würde ich
nie mit dieser distro machen was x w w w bra x w w w browser ja gut das moment das ist
jetzt das ist das program was die standard browsers durch geht installiert sind die ubuntu
repos sind von 2004 aber ich glaube dass diese programme also das war so das kennt diesen
das kennt diesen komischen das kennt diesen das gibt es gemäßig bei denen gar nicht
gibt es nicht also ich habe keine ahnung wie der browser da heißt ne ne ne leute ne komm
mit welchem shortcut schaust du dir die vorhandenen files an während du am schreiben bist du meinst
du meinst ne ne tap tap tap drücken tap tap das kann ich dir besser hier in der normalen
streaming vm zeigen so der muss weg open vm directory so remove yep remove und jetzt ganz
schnell recycle löschen weg so du meinst das hier ne dass du sagst tap tap ja du drückst
drückst einfach tap oder tap tap und dann kriegst du so ne so ne liste wo du durchscrollen
kannst was meinst zum build review im kde terminal hab ich noch nicht gesehen kenne
ich nicht genau doppelt tap also das was du eben gesehen hast war mit zsh aber bash kann
das auch bash kann das auch doppelt tap ja in vm kannst du mit manage assiste announcements
ok zeige ich mal her kde gear ok dolphin datamanager ocula pdf stels konsole ja finde ich ist ne
gute idee das finde ich ist ne gute idee hat was wobei ich halt kde programe auch nur teilweise
mag es ist eh schwierig ganz ehrlich ich benutze gerne linux ihr wisst ich verdiene im prinzip
mein geld mein geld mit linux aber programe die mir wirklich gefallen gibt es echt wenige
ist schwierig also es gibt es gibt es gibt vieles was überhaupt nicht meinen vorstellungen
entspricht entweder weil es einfach zu unfertig ist zu amateurhaft gemacht oder aber zu big
brain für mich gibt es ja auch beides beides es gibt welche die gefallen mir optisch nicht
und es gibt auch welche die mir von funktionen her nicht gefallen also ich hab ich wie gesagt
ich mag meine kombination aus gnome terminal mit dem t-max drin mit dem firefox oder einem
chrome als browser damit hast du 90 prozent abgefackelt was du brauchst ich hab jetzt was
neues gesehen letztens t-max alternative zenn zenn tally oder so z z tally vergessen wie das heißt rust
natürlich immer in rust z tally ja das habe ich letztes gesehen auf github das wollte ich
mal ausprobieren das ist jetzt quasi ein eine t-max alternative in rust warum in rust ich glaube
in rust damit man damit werben kann es ist in rust programmiert es gibt eigentlich zwei
programmiersprachen die gerne damit werben dass sie in der jeweiligen programmiersprache
programmiert sind das ist rust und das ist go beide projekte also projekte in beiden programmiersprachen
schreiben gerne dabei dass sie in der jeweiligen programmiersprache programmiert sind so nach
dem auto ist es in go es ist gleich viel besser es ist in rust es ist besser so ansonsten habe
ich ja mehr oder weniger alles browser wenn ich irgendeine idee brauche nehme ich meistens das
jetbrains zeug oder visual studio code und damit ist ohne mist erst mal 90 prozent von dem was
ich was ich so täglich verwende eigentlich abgefackelt ansonsten verwende ich halt relativ
viele shell tools und shell script in geschichten aber ansonsten so viel brauche ich da eigentlich
gar nicht ich brauche mein clipboard manager der ist der ist noch wichtig keqs service launcher
für programme ab und zu mal natürlich hier gparted und und screenshot tools das da für
notizen und ab und zu mal einen file manager aber ansonsten der sieht auch nicht so schön
gestylt aus weil ich da überhaupt nichts gemacht habe dran das war es mir brauche ich nicht habt
ihr euch schon das geleakte battlefield 2042 gameplay angeguckt nein haben wir nicht und ich
will das auch nicht auf stream zeigen weil es wahrscheinlich komplett dead gestrikt wird
auch überall von ea pipes rs das brauchen wir ganz wichtig neben neben dem ascii aquarium
brauchen wir noch pipes rs natürlich was sonst wie das gibt es nicht zum installieren
ach doch hier zwei hat ein stern immerhin cmatrix haben wir schon natürlich haben wir
cmatrix schon am start sl ist auch am start und die beste kombination ist ja immer noch
ach stimmt sl kann man ja standardmäßig nicht nicht abbrechen so sl ist immer noch
die beste kombination so da kann eigentlich nichts mehr schief gehen alles alles da also
die wichtig die die produktivsten tools sind schon am start also die produktivität produktivität
steigerung steigerungstools sind schon alle am start also die wichtigsten dinger haben
was aber selbst die basics ich habe die basics gemacht also kein ding so jetzt muss rast
erst mal drei stunden kompilieren neo fetsch habe ich glaube ich in seelen verwende ich
aber nicht weil ich den sinn davon ich sehe um ehrlich zu sein außer zu zeigen wie cool
man ist dass man so einen schönen prompt hat bestop habe ich nicht das mag ich nicht
ich kenne das ich mag diese diese übertriebenen status anzeigen nicht wo dann alles drin ist
ich habe lieber eine status anzeige für für das was ich brauche ich meine hardtop für
das ich mache dies denn für disk ist mir ist mir eigentlich lieber so jetzt kommt das
welche pipes hat es jetzt installiert ah yes ok jetzt bin ich zufrieden für heute deswegen
mag ich beispielsweise auch nicht netz nicht netz netz data heißt das glaube ich das war
mal eine zeit lang voll im trend dass die leute sich das auf alle ihre privaten heimserver
gemacht haben und ich mir immer gedacht habe was wollt ihr denn eigentlich damit da hast
du 50 billionen statistiken die sich keine sau jemals anguckt gut und auf produktive
server auf der arbeitsinit installieren hier sieht man übrigens wieder ich hoffe mal das
ist random hier sieht man übrigens mal wieder dran wie schöne randomness ist randomness
heißt nicht automatisch dass alles gleich verteilt ist am anfang das kann auch erstmal
sein dass alles sich in eine ecke klumpt aber wenn man das laufen lässt für einen tag
dann ist alles gleich verteilt halbwegs falls das random ist
welche programme wie cmatrix gibt es noch ja das beste ist ja immer noch hollywood naja
hollywood ist natürlich das allerwichtigste das braucht jeder also da kann man einfach
wieder richtiger kann man aussehen ich bin drin leute ich habs gleich ich habs gleich
die weltkarte die die story von der arbeit wo mal wo mal einer also der chef der chefs
dem der ganze laden gehört mal reingekommen ist und wie hollywood angemacht habe ich
ja glaube schon erzählt es hat sich mal der chef der oberchefs angekündigt bei uns auf
der arbeit und der wollte der wollte das den da wo unser 24 support sitzt besuchen und
ich sitze da ja auch obwohl ich nicht zum support gehör und da ist der chef fünf minuten
vorher reingekommen von von dem jeweiligen team und meinte so hey gleich kommt hier ober
ober ober boss tut tut man beschäftigt und da haben wir halt hollywood angemacht und
das kam dann auch so gut an dass er sich die monitore angeguckt hat hat gemeint was ihr
da wieder für dinger macht davon verstehe ich ja nix und da war er da war er ganz fand
er fand er ganz fand er ganz toll ja und der witz der witz war ja dann der witz war
ja dann und ich wette mit euch er weiß es ich weiß nicht mehr genau wie das wie das wie das ablief
das gespräch da gibt es ja nicht viel er läuft darum macht ein paar sprüche jetzt geht es dann
in nächsten zu dem nächsten team ich habe dann ich habe dann so was in der richtung gesagt wie
gesagt ich kriege es nicht mal hundertprozentig zusammen also er hat gemeint davon hat er ja keine
ahnung und dann habe ich so was gesagt in der richtung wieso ja ich eigentlich auch nicht wir
haben das bloß angemacht weil wir hören sie kommen vorbei und da haben wir uns eingucken
und in wirklichkeit dachte ich mir eigentlich der weiß 100 prozent dass das so ist die sind
doch nicht blöd die sind doch nicht blöd die wissen dass das so ist er musste halt lachen
das haben halt alle gelacht so nach dem motto ja ja ist ja ist ja gar nicht so ist ja gar nicht
so na wirklich kein witz wenn man alle dass es so ist ja war kein witz genau es hat halt nicht
also doch ich bin mir sicher da hat es kapiert ich bin mir sicher hat es kapiert kann man das
ja ich auch nach loll catpipen ah guck mal hier jetzt haben wir sogar super hyper farbige pipes
also die story stimmt nicht 100 pro es war irgendwie ein bisschen anders also von der
essenz her war es so aber der ablauf war ein bisschen anders ich glaube nicht dass es die
situation war wo wir hollywood auf hatten ich glaube ich habe irgendwie browser geswitcht
und desktops aber die essenz da draußen ist die gleiche wie machst du das noch mal einfach
das jeweilige programm start nach loll catpipen dann kommt da sowas bei raus wichtigstes programm
damit kannst du zum beispiel auch sowas hier machen echo cute chat nach toilet die wichtigste
aber die habe ich nicht drauf naja und das ganze loll catpipen hast du sowas dann hier
randomize cute chat
auch man das weiß ich nicht ob man die shell komplett durchlaufen lassen kann
wahrscheinlich nicht weil die read line brauchen für out für input keine ahnung habe ich nicht
habe ich nicht überlegt ob das ob das geht aber so ist das doch gut leider muss ich sagen
fazit elementary os also das ist nicht elementary os was ihr hier seht elementary os habe ich
schon habe ich schon runtergeschmissen leider muss ich sagen elementary os war nicht mein fall
ich will es nicht schlechter machen für die mühe die es die leute ergeben als es das verdient hat
aber mein fall war es nicht was soll ich mehr sagen hat mir jetzt nicht so angesprochen und
ich würde sagen wir machen beim nächsten stream weiter jetzt bettke machen bettke time
bettke
genau wupp bettke
schon spät ja schon spät
schnell schauen
ich hauste euch mal eine runde valorant
da ist der vetris grad am start der hat es verdient kollege von mir castet da gerade valorant
valorant könnte euch ja mal geben also leute